[VOCALIZING MUSIC]
[LAUGHTER]
Jennifer Stole my voice.
But if I get some water.
Let's do it.
Hi, I'm Jennifer Hudson.
And this is The Ultimate
RESPECT Playlist.
The first one is
"Accentuate the Positive."
She has this amazing super
sweet rendition of that song.
So as the first one.
Next--
"Georgia," by Emily
King-- autobiographical
and ambiguous simultaneously.
Obviously, "Never Loved A
Man The Way That I Love You."
Mahalia Jackson singing "Take
My Hand, Precious Lord."
You cannot have a RESPECT
playlist that does not include
Mahalia Jackson because
Mahalia Jackson meant so much
to the Franklin Family
and to Aretha's mom.
"Natural Woman," "Think,"
"Never Loved A Man,"
I could go on and on.
I'm going to add, "I Want
Magic," Renee Fleming.
Her iconic performance
of "Nessun Dorma."
That was one of the things
that really influenced
me to train in Opera.
Curtis Mayfield because there's
something very pimp about him.
"Freddie's Dead," "Pusherman."
The next one I picked is
Nina Simone, "Feeling Good,"
just because it reminds me of
some of Aretha's jazz and Kirby
recordings.
Definitely Sam Cooke, "A
Change Is Gonna Come."
And then, there's
a song that I wrote
called I took the
"You Outta Me" that
helps me get rid
of negative energy.
My next vote is "Jolene"
by Dolly Parton.
I just think that she
would have killed it
if she sang that song.
"Chain of Fools,"
oh, I love that song.
"Ain't No Way" because I
love hitting the high note.
[VOCALIZING] I hit it, just
not the key on the piano
that you're suppose to hit.
Of course, Aretha Franklin
singing "Amazing Grace."
My parents would listen to
this at least once a week.
I got to go with "RESPECT," one
of the greatest anthems ever
created.
Like how you do a movie called "RESPECT,"
and you ain't play RESPECT.
The R-E-S-P-E-C-T.
And that's the ultimate
RESPECT playlist.